Recall is a very high
bar to actually meet,
and the reason I think you
saw so many Californians is
because there's a real sense of urgency.
We want change now.
There's a connection
between what's going on in Sacramento
and the rising cost of living.
There's a connection between
what's going on in Sacramento
and the fact that people
are leaving California
for their first time.
The recall sent a very clear warning
to the rest of the nation
that California is not
a model for the nation.
It is a warning about the
perils of a corrupt government.
Those that think this thing is not close,
I hate to disabuse you, it is.
California Governor Gavin
Newsom is in trouble
and he knows it.
Newsom, who's facing a recall
vote on September 14th,
told the editorial board
of the Sacramento Bee
that his fellow Democrats
have been far too complacent
about the risk that he faces
and how damaging his loss
would be to the national party.
In Nancy Pelosi state, in Kamala Harris',
with California and the values we profess,
would be judged in a different light.
If this was a successful recall,
I think it would have
profound consequences.
Newsom's concerns are well-founded,
according to recent polls.
Because of COVID, the state has mailed
every eligible California voter a ballot
with two questions on it,
shall Gavin Newsom be recalled
from the office of Governor
and which of these 46
candidates should replace him,
if that were to happen?
If the recall succeeds,
whichever candidate receives
the plurality of votes will replace Newsom
until the next governor's race in 2022.
Newsom and his Democratic allies
have portrayed the election
as a right-wing plot to take
over California's government.
Who's behind the partisan recall
of Governor Gavin Newsom?
Anti-vaccine QAnon extremists,
violent white supremacists,
like the Proud Boys
who attacked our nation's
Capitol on January 6th,
and the same right-wing
Republican politicians
who supported Donald Trump's attempt
to overturn the election.
But what's actually
animating recall voters are
issues like rising homelessness,
high housing and energy
costs, fear of rising crime,
and COVID policies that have
little basis in science,
like closing beaches,
banning outdoor dining,
and keeping in-person
public schools shut longer
than any other state.
The recall should be as big a wake-up call
to the Democratic political establishment
as the population exodus
that recently caused California
to lose a congressional seat
for the first time in its history.
Everyone loves you.
Everyone is talking about
how you've handled this.
Early in the pandemic,
Newsom was second only to New
York Governor Andrew Cuomo
in the adoration he received
from celebrities and the media
for his COVID response.
One of the governors who acted earliest,
with regards to the coronavirus.
You've been getting a lot of praise
for shutting things down.
The pandemic briefly turned Newsom
into a national hero,
and he touted California
as a global beacon.
Absolutely, we see this as an opportunity
to reshape the way we do
business and how we govern.
And as a model of progressive governance
that he claimed would change
American politics forever.
What's the opportunity, to your question,
for re-imagining a more progressive era,
as it relates to capitalism?
But as flattening the curve morphed
into indefinite lockdowns?
The schools should be closed.
The schools will be closed.
[Correspondent 1] He says
a return to life as normal
in that state will not
happen any time soon.
We are committed to a process,
we've socialized that process,
and we are leaning in.
And the case rates surged regardless.
With California announcing
a record 71 deaths in one day.
Newsom acted as if, for him, the rules
that were paralyzing
the state's restaurant
and nightlife scene didn't apply.
While Governor Newsom is telling all of us
to have Thanksgiving dinner outside,
he's facing some new fallout
for that fancy birthday dinner party
he went to at The French Laundry.
He's implemented rules that
we would gladly follow,
but I don't think he's
setting the best example.
I think it's highly hypocritical of him.
The petition to recall surpassed
the required one and a
half million signature mark
in February 2021 and officially
made the ballot in July.
If Gavin Newsom were an
employee in my corporation,
I would have fired him
a long damn time ago.
For Orrin Heatlie,
the retired Yolo County Sheriff Sergeant
who started the recall petition
six months before COVID hit,
illegal immigration was
a motivating factor.
His open border policy,
giving our tax money
to illegal immigrants for
housing, food, and clothing
when our own citizens are on the street,
our own veterans are
homeless on the street.
Newsom, in turn, has pointed to his role
as evidence that the
recall effort is a plot
by right-wing extremists,
pointing to substantial funding
from the California GOP
and Mike Huckabee's PAC,
and highlighting in particular comments
that Heatlie posted to Facebook
that called for microchipping
illegal immigrants.
People keep going back to
this Facebook comment you made
about tagging illegal
immigrants like herd animals.
Absolutely against mandatory
chipping of anybody.
That was a statement made in hyperbole
to generate conversation,
and yeah, it was not well-worded
and not the right thing to put out there.